hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer a question
from one of my readers to me saying who
is asking about starting a new
technology company so we wrote insane I
want to start an IT firm that deals with
apps but I'm a creative person and I
don't have the coding skills I just
finished my university program in
finance and economics and it's been
running a promotional business for four
years where do I start where do I go so
to me saying thanks for the question a
very common question I get asked by a
lot of companies who are trying to get
started in technology usually in
technology you'll find you need two
people to get it going you have the guy
who's really good at coding and the guy
who's really good at sales and marketing
and very very rarely do those skills
overlap you shouldn't need the person
who's super good at that coding and
usually those guys are not really
extroverted and want to go out and do
the sales and marketing and usually the
sales and marketing guys have an
understanding the technology but they're
not the high-end coders who can really
take your company to the next level so
it's very common in technology and just
look at Apple's an example you had Steve
Jobs who was a sales and marketing guy
the visionary you know building the
company and Steve Wozniak who was the
coder the engineer who was creating all
the great technology for the company so
for you it's finding that extra person
so there's two ways to do it if you're
the sales and marketing guy you need to
find the coder you need to find the
technology genius is going to help you
build your company and together you can
do great things so the two ways to do it
is one find a partner so like Apple and
you have your you know Co partner and
you find your Steve Wozniak or you hire
somebody to come on and help you what I
found is the partner roof ship route is
usually the best way to go but it all
depends on finding the right person
starting a partnership is like getting
married and make sure you have to have
that right person on board you have a
good relationship with and you can be
with for a fairly long time because it's
going to hopefully take that long with
your business
with your hiring somebody then you're
always at the mercy of their knowledge
and they may not be as emotionally tied
to the company because they don't own a
piece of it it's really hard to be a
technology company without having a
technology person who's really committed
to the company so if they walk up and
leave because they don't have any kind
of equity stake in the business you're
really stuck and so you really want to
have that person on board as much as
possible and you may at the start just
start off hiring some people to get you
going build the technology up but I
would look for an arc for the future to
have somebody that you can really trust
be your partner in this business to help
get it going so I wouldn't lose hope I
think there's a lot of opportunity you
just need to make sure you find that
right person to be able to work with to
build the company and there's a lot of
guys who are on the other end of the
situation where they're the coders of
the technology guys with great ideas and
they just wish they found somebody who
could help them be the Steve Jobs and
sales marketing grow that business for
them so hopefully that helps
if you guys liked the video I'd love to
hear what you have to say if you want to
leave a comment under the video and it
also always appreciate any thumbs up -
you want to gives on YouTube and stay
tuned for next episode
you